ils vont tous faire leur entrée vous
allez voir c'est du très très lourd ce
soir c'est notre défilé c'est pour vous
qu'on l'a préparée et vous nous direz
pour vous qui a eu le meilleur look ce
soir d'accord qui a fait le meilleur des
filets http défilé je sais que vous
aimez ce genre de choses il ya il ya des
très gros dos je vous le dis je kiffe
on va démarrer on va démarrer avec le la
première à défiler c'est parti
applaudissements poil
[Applaudissements]
quoi
soir bonsoir vous n'êtes ni nourriture
dans la colle dans la colle alors pour
nina ricci de la colle bien sûr voté un
cerveau ni leurs études à l'école est
très bien ça pourrait bien sonner
attention attention c'est parti
deuxième mannequin on y va
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes qui pour nos
téléspectateurs
marc jacob delafon merci aux acteurs de
la pauvreté de ses ambitions
attention pour l'instant c'est du très
bon et vous allez voir il ya du très
très très local moi j'ai une petite
préférence pour quelqu'un je pense tout
de suite comprendre de qui il s'agit
aller 3è mannequin c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
bon
ça je ne sens pas je le sens pas je sais
pas si vous êtes qui une bande son c'est
comment ai-je pu tenir aussi
à les convoquer pour hugo broos je pense
à calais beaucoup vous votez 3 à l'aise
et partie kpn
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez droit
vous êtes qui bat coco chanel coco
[Applaudissements]
chanel était très drôle merci pour tout
pousse à mal bien sûr
franchement il ya un délire mais le
meilleur reste à venir pour moi le
meilleur reste êtes vous dit j'ai une
petite préférée malgré ça dans un
instant allez c'est parti
5e
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ont montré comme ça sinon là bas ne
marche pas vous êtes vous
ben ça soit 7 qui je suis jean paul
gaultier jean paul bussières est la
triste araya vous êtes vous êtes ou
encore goodyear m et la marinière
s'alluma jamila ben ont démarré sa femme
étaient tous là et c'est très bien merci
jean paul merci jean paul ii
moi non
[Applaudissements]
oh
maman
[Applaudissements]
il ya les ventes s'élèvent en paix mais
vous êtes qui bah je suis giorgio armani
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
nature dorment amis je suis fan de st
gall merci aujourd'hui on m'a mis en
panne moteur du rab y aller le prochain
repas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
abhorré brabo 1
attends je vais te le registre les non
c'est bon vous êtes qui je suis pas
cours à ben merci bateau attention
prochain match
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
avec
[Applaudissements]
moi ça et qui sut karl lagerfeld chez
vous je suis cerruti groupe regarder y
aura-t-il un mannequin mais ça y est tu
peux nous faire un peu relancés s'il
vous plaît relancé plus tôt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la la la
boubou quelle classe connais très bien
les lieux par quelques heures toutes les
deux c'est pas les vraies dents mais
elle vous avez vu sa sublime épouse à
ses initiales elle sait qu'à des us et
un centre il ne détenait pas les u7
sewell fais pas ça donne pas par mark et
moi aussi ça donne pas pareil c'est pas
le même désir c'est pas le même failli
c'est un truc de ouf qui manquent
ah ben on va voir tout de suite
[Applaudissements]
ou à
alors quand je vous disais que ça fait
pas pareil je ne vous ai pas bon je ne
vous ai pas menti
franchement je ne vous ai pas menti vous
êtes de leurs sacs plastiques et
franchement c'est ces exceptions
bravo franchement bravo styliste créé
[Applaudissements]